le centre pompidou à paris fermé pour
cause de rajeunissement contrairement à
certaines rumeurs et certaines
informations qui couraient ces derniers
temps sur la vétusté voir le le
délabrement de l'édifice le centre
pompidou se porte bien mais il est
victime de son succès alain doublé ce
qui est daniel levy nous offre une
petite visite que je qualifierais de
techniques 1 27 mille visiteurs par jour
au lieu des sept mille prévus à
l'origine
certains jours le centre pompidou reçoit
jusqu'à 40000 visiteurs qui se partage
entre la visite du musée d'art moderne
le centre de création industrielle
l'institut de recherche musicale et
surtout la bibliothèque 1700 places
assises toujours prises d'assaut face à
une telle sollicitation
il y a eu lui rapide et passages
réservés au public moquette rampe
d'accès aux heures d'ouverture des
milliers de personnes passent ici
les expertises ont démontré que la
structure du bâtiment était en bon état
bien sûr la mauvaise qualité d'une
peinture recouvrant une poutrelle du
cinquième étage fait mauvais effet ainsi
que celle ci d'ailleurs mais la sécurité
des visiteurs n'est pas remise en cause
on a dit des choses permettez moi de
dire absurde sur la sécurité nous ne
sommes pas l'endroit où le boulon tombe
il y en a quelques uns
nous sommes un endroit où on a besoin de
travaux et bien évidemment il ya des
problèmes de corrosion il ya des
problèmes de maintenance comme dans tout
bâtiment et ça c'est de beaba la gestion
quotidienne d'un bâtiment qui nous pose
aucun problème de sécurité
aucun problème en revanche qui doit être
complètement revu ses lacs et la
présentation des expositions ont su il
ya 20 ans le musée a pris un coup de
vieux comparé au louvre par exemple le
coût du chantier est évalué à 400
millions de francs
faudra-t-il fermer le centre pompidou
pendant les travaux pendant combien de
temps
réponse dans quelques jours